every night you see
what's the craziest you saw in your
four years third night out of the
academy out on the street with an fto we
find a I found a
decapitated head come on dude just yeah
guy uh what do you mean you found it 19
year old Georgia Tech Student committed
suicide by laying his head across some
train tracks and you guys are just out
there cruising around and you look over
and see ahead or you got a call we got a
call that there's a mannequin on some
train tracks oh no and we both were like
I think I literally even said like
that's an odd reason to call the police
and we get there and uh not a mannequin
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]
foreign